In the native Java Datastore API, all property
values are indexed by default. If you forget to
think carefully about which properties really need to be
indexed, you could end up with index bloat. However,
objectify helps you out and by default property
values are not indexed when you use objectify. So,
if you want a property to be indexed, you
need to add the @Index annotation to the property.
However, if you prefer that by default all
the properties of a class are indexed, then you
add the @Index annotation to the class and
then you can add @UnIndex to each property that
you don't want to be indexed. You can
also add conditions so that a property's only indexed
if it meets certain criteria. For example, only index
a property if the value is greater than 100.
There's good documentation about conditional indexing in the
Objectify Developer's Guide. So what I'm going to want you
to do next, is actually go read the developer's
guide. It's at this link, or actually an easier
way to find it is just to search
on Google for objectify. This brings you down into
the open-source project for objectify. Then you click on
the wiki. And then, expand the users guide and
you go to the queries and indexes page.